- My lung collapsed, I have no ribs, but we need to ATTACK.
- Taysom, I need you to confuse Twitter again.
- ON IT, SIR.
- That’s cute, but we need someone to carry us past the Bucs.
- Ayo, what's up, man? How's everybody doing?
- This is the NFC South Lead.
Deliver us to the postseason.
- Oh, now we get targets.
- Guard him well, Kamara.
- NO ONE CAN GUARD ME!
Oh no...I'm...suspended.
Remember...your...all-purpose.
Ow, damn.
[Suspenseful music]
- Yo, chill out, plane.
- [Matt Ryan:] OH NO, NOT AGAIN.
We’re actually getting it together under Raheem Morris!
[Loud crash]
- FOURNETTE, JONES EYE EYE. RUN DOWN RUNNING MAN.
- YOU’RE FINISHED, KAMARA.
- Oh wait, four yards. We’re good.
- Man, how is Madden gonna give me an 88?
- WHY ARE WE RUNNING?
Thank you for keeping up, camera.
- We have the same enemy.
Good luck, and f--k the Bucs.
- WHO RULES?
- [Together:] MATT RHULES!!
- Ayo this is lit.
- YO, YOU’LL NEVER TAKE MY DIVISION.
- Ya, I'm going to blame Tom for not shooting better.
- THE FIRST RULE OF MATT RHULE IS...
- [Together:] MATT RULES!
- THE SECOND RULE OF MATT RHULE IS....
- THE THIRD RULE OF MATT RHULE IS…
- [Together:] Address the culture first, trust Joe Brady, and don’t worry
about winning games until 2021.
- Correct.